welcome to this video playing Jesus from
the Netherlands again yeah this is quite
a good line d5 and d6 leads to
interesting play we probably get them
benoni mm-hmm yep is some preventing
before
I need to get some lines opened don't
wander completely closed position with
them a disadvantage in space yeah like
probably just plays Knight f6 nine maybe
e5 also possible yeah this I didn't
think I thought I could play here
because I'm a taking c5 yes but this
leads to a really big action development
ok
yeah just here and now this is this is
actually a pretty good position for
white it's um it's difficult difficult
for black to play it should we do look
big to me as putting pressure on b7
yeah I think I have very good
compensation here
I should have really done something
against Bishop g4 though but them James
probably not the end of the world b7 is
saying
yeah this guy's from the Netherlands
easiest to fall for some that same guys
are returning returning that could go h3
Bishop f3 knight Bishop e3 hmm away is
castletown them
yeah this is stupid now no Bishop t4
isn't particularly great this was really
unnecessary a Sri was just very stupid
ok shubh f6 Bishop f1
okay let's try that it's not it's not to
supply this position do you do those
weaknesses I didn't necessarily need it
to two sec the exchange but it's
interesting okay so check he immediately
reach answered cannot cannot not return
it so on group cheeks I guess want to
I want to keep keep it active so let's
let's check it with a tank no a foyer
this prevents b5 if he goes to 8 f king
everyone covering the squares are
threatening group d 6 and rook b6 to be
five so this is some better end game now
for white young winning a pawn no reason
not to take it
he still suffers from this week d4 pawn
this means IAM has a hard time to
activate his route the rock always needs
to stay on the d file I mean maybe at
some point he needs to think about
sacrificing something but then it's it's
difficult to to do okay maybe I go here
to have on be 685 I don't want to be 6
rook moves look I'm a 7 attend upon a
saying so this is a good prophylactic
news I hope
let's take a fly fan all threatening
look b6 and takes on g6 and it's a it's
all protected here okay this doesn't
really threaten much this is covered
check so why can I can take him and Jung
ji form
g for intakes hmm probably and this is
some probably enough yeah it is enough
it is enough rope f5 does look g4 and
takes on d4 rook a3 does look g3
gathering and look f3 and then the f
porn runs yes that's it it's over yeah i
won Wendy for now
mmm
it's rocky rocky fire for so as a key
component game Cantus should win
I don't tell me it's not winning this
would be really a shame if I'm first
pawn that it was a bad decision really
this was a bad decision simply because
the the rook endgame was very easy win I
think it's winning it is Winningham we
have this kind of position where those
pawns protect each other he can never
take one of them but it was it was
unnecessary really because the the rook
endgame wasn't easy win and this could
have looked really surely the king of
porn endgame mrs. winning with with an
extra porn but here ok ok now it was it
was ok but it you always need to be
cautious I mean maybe there is a case
where it is a draw and if you if you
simply don't do it and play any move
like whatever some it's not really
somewhere and this is quite easy win in
the loop end game 2 points is too much a
decade it was winning it's a yam some
some some strange play here h3 I
miscalculated I thought ok cannot really
go here but um ok I went for this for
this exchange sec now yeah this is this
is interesting the computer is very
pessimistic and thinks that white is
just lost year and this is a wrong a
role evaluation this is quite clear why
is not lost him he might be worse but
he's not lost simply am because of the
activity would be a test from a mistake
book v6 and here i'm already i'm already
somewhat better check but he could have
played better here of course clean
deform went right into this very bad end
game he played this also very quickly in
one second year term obviously blended
beforehand I thought maybe Queenie seven
or something this rook is also a bit a
bit off here or south side and after
that it was just it was just this is the
st. game and I think this is really a
lost end game like has a hard time not
to lose a pawn and then he's sitting
there with the worst structure and and
and no activity especially this look has
no way to activate itself this kind of
idea always fades to the King covering
the squares so this is a very bad end
game very bad end game okay thanks for
watching